yeah rattling along yeah
so this picture this bit is universally
accepted right this is this model of
quantum mechanics that says that there
is an answer you can't you know there's
uncertainty in the position a momentum
of a particle they're not you can't have
both of them at the same time isn't
controversial
this is still controversial and in fact
they're not quite measuring the same
thing right this is really measuring the
position and momentum of a particle at
the same time or knowing what the
position and momentum of a particle at
the same time are this is a thing called
a measurement disturbance relation right
i'm making a measurement and in the
purpose process of making the
measurement i'm disturbing the very
thing i'm measuring they're not quite
the same thing
and so interestingly people are still
arguing today
are they you know is this
thought experiment heisenberg's actually
right can we beat that uncertainty
relation just by being cleverer about it
and a couple of years ago
someone came up with a way of saying
actually yes there is a way of defeating
this we can we can actually do better
than this in certain types of
measurement now it's a very subtle thing
to try and do because if you actually
think about it if you want to say okay
so if you're doing this measurement
disturbing thing if i measure something
i will intrinsically disturb it just by
making the measurement and then you ask
the question so how much do i disturb it
by i want to measure how much i've
disturbed this particle by by making
this measurement now in order to measure
how much you've disturbed it by you need
to know where what its momentum was to
start with to find out how much you've
changed it by so i need to know what his
momentum wants to start with well then i
need to measure its momentum but we've
just argued that you can't actually
measure it so it's slightly circular
kind of thing that i need to know what
the particle's momentum is before i
started to find out how much i disturb
it by but that's a measurement in itself
there's a whole new field of quantum
mechanics which has just come to the
fore in the last few years the thing
called weak measurement
which is people have found ways of
making very subtle measurements in
quantum systems which don't disturb the
system very much
and so you make
even subtler measurements than this
each individual measurement you make it
turns out is completely rubbish because
actually you're doing this very subtle
thing and not you know trying very very
gently not to disturb the system at all
and in the process you'll find that
actually each individual measurement you
make isn't very good
but by averaging together a whole load
of these weak measurements you can
actually learn something about the
quantum mechanical properties of the
system without disturbing it people came
up with his way of actually trying to do
this kind of experiment
and a couple of years ago came up with a
result which seemed to do better than
the heisenberg relationship said you
could do
then just last year somebody else wrote
a paper that said actually no you've
done this you've done the maths wrong
basically and said that really and it's
to do with how you measure
the answer
the degree of uncertainty the degree of
disturbance you've introduced because
it's not you need some you need some
sort of figure of merit have i disturbed
it little or a lot
and there are different ways you can
quantify how much you've disturbed the
system and the the argument was well
you've actually just used the wrong
figure of merit for figuring out how
much you disturb the system and when we
do it our way because we're doing it
right we get back to heisenberg's
relationship again
it sounds like it's a slightly sort of
uh esoteric argument but it turns out it
has some implications because
there's a
whole field developing of a thing called
quantum cryptography where people are
using quantum mechanical systems to
encode messages obviously it's a way of
getting you know getting messages around
without people figuring out what you're
saying so you know secret messages sent
by code and the beauty at least in
principle of quantum cryptography
is that if there is this relationship
between making a measurement and
disturbing things
then when somebody
eavesdrops on your signal listens in
just that act of of eavesdropping
listening in will disturb the system and
you'll be able to see that your message
has been tampered with and so you can
tell they really you know this really is
the ultimate in security because you can
tell whether somebody's kind of steamed
the envelope open because they have left
this imprint in the in the the very
thing that they were trying to measure
through these measurement disturbance
relations
if it turns out you can beat these
measurement disturbance relations and
actually detect things about that signal
and without disturbing things then it
means that quantum cryptography doesn't
work
so getting an answer to this of can we
defeat this heisenberg
measurement
disturbance relation has very
fundamental implications for whether
this entire field of quantum
cryptography is doomed to actually never
be any use for anything it's fascinating
right this is just something that
heisenberg put out there as this elegant
little kind of back of the envelope
demonstration as to how there was this
problem we're trying to both you know
trying to measure something without
disturbing it here we are almost 100
years later and we still haven't figured
out actually whether he was right or not
and actually figuring out whether he was
right or not will have these much bigger
implications for for whether quantum
cryptography works or not this weak
measurement yeah how does that work
what are they doing they're not shining
photons in there
there's a whole another video i think is
the short answer to that all right give
me a taste of what will be in that other
video so what do you do in weak
measurement if you have so you can buy
with different types of quantum system
you can set things up so that the amount
you can you can kind of have if you like
in
you can almost say
almost actually in practice have a dial
which is dictates how strongly
one particle will interact with another
just from the way you set up one
particle then you can you can just have
you know you can have a piece of
apparatus which will actually allow you
to dial up or down how strongly another
partner was going to interact with that
particle
okay and what you do in weak measurement
is you dial that all the way down almost
to zero
which means that there is almost no
interaction between the particles
which means that you've disturbed the
system very little but of course it
means that actually you get very little
information because there's been very
little interaction
and there is this clever trick you know
the i the thing i don't fundamentally
understand about this is i think it
ought to be a zero-sum game right that
actually you know you get so little
information that i have to make
thousands and thousands of measurements
to actually learn anything at all and
then surely i'm just disturbing the
thing just by making thousands of little
observations instead of one big one
turns out that's not the case right you
can actually learn stuff
without disturbing the system very much
at all by averaging together a whole lot
of a whole lot of measurements well so
they say someone else disagree well no
no everyone agree and i think people
agree that weak measurement more or less
works whether or not it's a way of
getting around the heisenberg
measurement disturbance relation is
another question
then actually photons going in a very
wide range of possible directions
will all end up going through the lens